nous vous convions maintenant à nous
suivre dans une station de sport d'hiver
pas comme les autres cette station c'est
avoria la station de jeanvu harnais
jeanvu harnais était l'un des promoteurs
de cette station qui sur le côté
architectural a été bâti par l'atelier
d'architecture d'avoria composé de
Jacques Labau Jean-Jacques orzoni et
Jean-Marc
rock mais passons en revue les diverses
raisons qui font que cette station n'est
pas du tout comme les
autres jeanvu
hernet jeanvunet vous venez de faire le
tour de la station d'avorias avec un
moyen de transport peu commun pourquoi
et bien si vous voulez c'est
l'illustration au final de d'un de nos
d'un de nos trois grands principe qui
régit le l'implantation d'Avoriaz à
savoir la station sans voiture et pour
bien frapper les imaginations nous avons
fait venir des reennes de Laponie de
Finlande avec des traîneaux très
typiques que vous avez vu à
l'instant vous savez que les deux autres
principes sont d'une part l'adaptation
absolue et totale de du fonctionnement
de notre station au ski c'est-à-dire que
l'implantation des champs de ski des
pistes ont présidé à l'implantation du
plan masse par les architecte et enfin
troisème point le dépaysement
dépaysement que nous recherchons non pas
en cherchant à faire des des chalets
souvenirs ou des chalets type Suisse
mais euh une architecture moderne
parfaitement adap adaptée au sites et
euh néanmoins euh euh si vous voulez qui
ne ressemble en aucune façon à ce qu'on
appelle communément les valises c'est
dire ces espèces de d'immeubles
classiques qu'on trouve parfaitement
dans les villes et qui ne dépayissent
pas les touristes de nos stations si
vous deviez donner un slogan court à
votre station lequel serait-il et bien
je crois que ce serait quand même euh
avec nos reenes euh avoria station sans
voiture je crois que dans votre station
vous avez voulu différencier les deux
types de circulation expliquez-nous ce
plan vous voyez clairement que les
skilleurs passent au-dessus des
circulations cell queon voit il y a à
gauche et circulations lourd qui servent
au service public et les circulations
légères qui sont des promenades ou des
navettes intérieures à la station au
nord vous voyez des un bonhomme qui
arrive avec ses skis et au sud vous en
voyez un autre qui part avec ces skis
autrement dit ce schéma illustre bien la
façon dont les gens vivront dans la
station c'est-à-dire qu'ils se
déplaceront uniquement à ski et bien
après avoir vu les maquettees de tous
nos projets nous voici maintenant sur le
terrain et vous pouvez voir les
premières réalisations euh ces
réalisations sont d'un caractère
extrêmement moderne très originale aussi
je crois conçu par une bande de jeunes
architectes qui ont dés dirait cherchait
aussi bien à s'adapter au site par le
caractère de l'architecture de même
qu'il l'avait fait pour le plan masse
les bâtiments que vous pouvez voir ici
bien que n'étant pas encore complètement
terminé seront complètement transformés
lorsqu'ils seront couvert entièrement en
bois il s'agit de de toit en bois Cèdre
rouge comme nous appelons
ici ces éléments les tavaillons les
celles comme vous voudrez et bien voici
maintenant nous sommes à peu près acav
ont tous les habitants des immeubles qui
donnent tous sur les pistes en plein sud
dès maintenant les les les touristes de
Morzine peuvent venir skier à avoria
avec de nombreuses pistes et des
installations assez extraordinaires
notamment notre notre énorme
téléphérique qui débite plus de 1000
personnes à l'heure et qui est le plus
rapide du monde avec ses 12 M25 secondes
nous avons également un télésiège qui
fonctionne un grand tééi un plus petit
pour les débutants et nous sommes un peu
pris de cours nous sommes en train de
terminer un télésiège et un téléski qui
présenteront sur le plateau d'avoria les
champs de ski pour tout
débutant je pense que dès l'année
prochaine nous serons avec quelques
centaines de lits fort bien équipés au
point de vue monontée mécanique avec ce
programme entièrement
réalisé